hi my name is Sidney goldstein and on
behalf of Stephen Barclay and me it's a
pleasure to invite to welcome you here
to this very special lunch I'm sure a
lot of you know that City Arts &
Lectures is in the midst of celebrating
its 15th anniversary season of
presenting concerts
I said concerts it's interesting we did
our first concert on Saturday night with
lattice knight and Terry Gross but of
primarily presenting lectures and
onstage conversations with leading
figures and literature criticism and the
Performing Arts and in the past week and
a half we have done Steve and I seem to
have managed to present just about every
kind of event we know how to do and
today we're doing what we know how to do
best which is put ourselves in the hands
of our friends at the Hay Street grill
patricia Unterman doris clarity john
bissell and all the people here at the
Hay Street grill tony moore in the
kitchen who seems to have been cooking
for us non-stop for the last 72 hours
they take such good care of us and
they're a very important part of the
work that we do I'm sure that all of you
know that the Hay Street Grill has
become the sort of algonquin of San
Francisco except that the food is a lot
better
and I don't know how many of you know
that there was a dinner here the other
night for Salman Rushdie with every
major artist in the Bay Area and it
happened here in part not just because
the food is good and because the service
is great but Patricia Unterman whose
restaurant this is is one of the most
well read people I've ever met I don't
know how many people not only read all
of the Satanic Satanic Verses of Salman
Rushdie but also had read his new novel
two weeks ago so we're especially glad
to be here to be celebrating our 15th
anniversary with our very first guest
who appeared at the herps theatre 15
years ago Fran Lebowitz
and it's especially good that we've been
able to turn the Hay Street Grill into a
private setting because it's the only
way that Fran would be able to be
comfortable and be able to smoke Fran
Lebowitz is the author of two
best-selling collections of essays
Metropolitan Life and social studies
she's been referred to as a modern-day
Dorothy Parker but to my mind she's a
lot better writer after dropping out of
high school in New Jersey and you should
know that Fran's parents are here right
now Ruth and Harold and last night Ruth
said if Fran would go back to school
they would pay for it
Fran moved from New Jersey to New York
and quickly established herself I don't
think they were kidding quickly
established herself as a most
independent and gifted wit among other
less literary jobs
she wrote a column called I covered the
waterfront for Andy Warhol's interview
magazine most recently as a serious
advocate of reading and education
she wrote a children's book titled mr.
Chaz and Lisa su meat the Panda and the
book is illustrated by Michael Graves
and I think there are copies of it in
the next room after overcoming ten years
of writer's block
Fran is finishing her first novel
exterior signs of wealth and while while
she is widely appreciated as one of
America's most original and tireless
wits sometimes overlooked is the fact
that she is a uniquely artful writer and
she works hard at it another fact that
might not be completely evident is that
Fran Lebowitz is a most generous and
loyal friend and it gives me great
pleasure to introduce her to you once
again please welcome Fran Lebowitz
thank you
these are my backup readers I said tip I
picked up from Gladys Knight for those
of you who are here for some in rush day
um I hope you won't be disappointed this
won't be quite a suspenseful I hope what
I'm gonna do is maybe read one or two
things from this book both my books were
put into one book disappointing to me
that that was possible and then I'm
going to answer questions from the
audience in an entertaining fashion you
don't have to ask them in an
entertaining fashion in fact I would
actually prefer that you don't make that
attempt I think the the piece I'm gonna
read is called no I can't remember him
well it's called diary of a New York
apartment hunter it was written you know
quite a long time ago
I mean both of these books were written
when I was actually in my 20s and I'm
now not in my 20s
so that you can see that it was bad even
then when I read this out of town
although probably not in San Francisco
people think of science fiction a diary
of a New York apartment hunter Friday
awakened at the crack of dawn by a
messenger of burying this come in
Sunday's New York Times real estate
section first six apartments gone
already
spend a good 15 minutes dividing the
number of New York Times editors into
the probable number of people looking
for two-bedroom apartments spent
additional half hour wondering how
anyone who has a paper to get out every
day could possibly have time to keep up
1,100 friendships realize that this
theory not plausible and decided instead
that the typesetter is all of them
co-ops with wood-burning fireplaces
wondered briefly why listings always
specify wood-burning fireplaces decided
that considering the prices they're
asking it's probably just a warning
device for those who might otherwise
figure what the hell and just burn money
called the f and inquire politely as to
whether anyone in his extremely
desirable building had died during the
night applying the negative I just don't
get it it's quite a large building and
no one in it has died for months in my
tiny little building they're dropping
like flies made a note to investigate
the possibility that high ceilings and
decorative moldings prolong life
momentarily chilled by the thought that
someone who lives in a worse building
than mine is waiting for me to die
sheera measurably my realization that a
nobody lives in a worse building than
mine and be particularly those who are
waiting for me to die Saturday uptown to
look a co-op in venerable Midtown
building meant real-estate broker and
Lobby a Caucasian version of Tokyo Rose
she immediately launched into a
description of all the respectively
employed people who are waiting a line
for this apartment showed me living room
first large Airy toward a few of
well-known discount drugstore two
bedrooms
sure enough kitchen sort of when I asked
why the present occupant has seen fit to
cut three five hood high arches out of
the inside wall of the master bedroom
she muttered something about cross
ventilation when I pointed out that
there were no windows on the opposite
wall she ostentatiously extracted a
sheaf of papers from her briefcase and
studied them closely presumably these
contain the names of all the Supreme
Court justices who are waiting for this
apartment
nevertheless I pressed on and after what
one might do with three five foot high
arches and one's better in walls she
suggested stained glass I suggested pews
in the living room and services on
Sunday she showed me a room she referred
to as the master bath I asked her where
the slaves bathe
she wrestled her papers ominously and
showed me the living room again I looked
as gruntled she brightened and showed me
something called a fun bathroom it had
been covered in fabric from floor to
ceiling by someone who obviously was not
afraid to mix patterns I informed her
unceremoniously that I never again
wanted to be shown a fun bathroom I
don't want to have fun in the bathroom
I just want to bathe my slaves she
showed me the living room again either
she just couldn't get enough of that
discount drugstore or she was trying to
trick me into thinking there were three
living room impudently I asked her where
1/8 seeing as I had not been shown a
dining room and the kitchen was
approximately the size of a brandy
snifter
well she said some people use the second
bedroom as a dining room I replied that
I need the second bedroom to write in
this was a mistake because it reminded
her of while the ambassador to the UN on
her list of prospective tenants
well she said the master bedroom is
rather large listen I said I already eat
on my bed in a one room rent control of
slum apartment I'll eat on the bed
Andrew innately praised him in his coop
I want to eat at a table call me silly
call me foolish but that's the kind of
girl I am
she has squirted me out of the apartment
and left me standing in the lobby as
sherry as she hurried off anxious no
doubt to call Cardinal O'Connor and tell
them okay the apartment was hit
Sunday spent the entire day we're
covering from a telephone call with the
real estate broker who in response to my
having expressed displeasure at having
been shown an apartment and which the
closest thing to a closet had been in
the living room said well Fran what do
you expect for thirty four hundred a
month he hung up before I could tell him
that actually to tell you the truth for
thirty four hundred a month I expected
the Winter Palace furnished
not to mention fully staffed Monday look
this morning at the top floor of the
building which I have privately
christened Uncle Tom's brownstone one
end of the floor slopes sufficiently for
me to be able to straighten up and ask
why the refrigerator it was in the
living room I was promptly put in my
place by the owner who looked me
straight in the eye and said because it
doesn't fit in the kitchen true I
conceded taking a closer look that is a
problem I'll tell you what though and
this may not have occurred to you but
that kitchen does fit in the
refrigerator why don't you try it I left
before he could act on my suggestion and
repair it to a phone booth mortality
rate and VF building still amazingly low
called about apartment listen today's
paper
was told fixture fee $100,000 replied
that unless Rembrandt had doodled on the
walls $100,000 wasn't a fixture fee it
was war reparations Tuesday let
desperation get the best of me and went
to see an apartment described as
interesting interesting generally means
that has a skylight no elevator and
they'll throw in the glassine envelopes
for free this one was even more
interesting than usual because the
broker for me Jack Kerouac had once
lived here someone's pulling your leg I
told him Jack Kerouac's still living
here Wednesday
ran into a casual acquaintance on 7th
Avenue turns out he too is looking for a
two-bedroom apartment we compared notes
did you see the one with the
refrigerator in the living room he asked
yes indeed I said well he said today I
looked at a dentist's office in the East
50s a dentist office I said was the
chair still there no he replied but
there was a sink in every room it
sounded like a deal for someone
called real-estate broker and inquired
as to price of newly advertised co-op
amount in substantial six figures
what about financing I asked financing
she shuddered audibly this is an
all-cash building I told her that to me
an all-cash building is what you put on
boardwalk or Park Place she suggested
that I look further uptown I replied
that if I looked any further uptown I'd
have to take karate lessons she thought
that sounded like a good idea
Thursday was shown coop apartment a
recently deceased actor by now so
seasoned that I didn't bat an eye at the
sink in the master bedroom assumed that
either he was a dentist on the side or
that it didn't fit in the bathroom
second assumption proved correct
couldn't understand why though you think
that there not being a shower and there
would have left penny of room the first
day real estate broker pointed out
recent improvements tangerine colored
kitchen appliances bronze mirrored
fireplace a fun living room
told the broker that what with the
asking price the maintenance and the
cost of unimproved
I couldn't afford to live there and
still wear shoes on a regular basis
called VF again first the good news a
woman in his building died then the bad
news she decided not to move thank you
I think I'm gonna risk this um I'm gonna
be this short piece for me that last
piece was very long piece this is called
pointers for pets this was written
before you know the recent done
tremendous some vivid compassion for
animals but um now of course probably
this will be like a salmon Rushdie
reading pointers for pets I feel
compelled by duty to begin this
discourse with what I actually think of
as a statement but will more probably be
construed as an admission I do not like
animals of any sort I don't even like
the idea of animals animals are no
friends of mine
they are not welcome in my house they
occupy no space in my heart
animals are off my list I will say
however in the spirit of qualification
that I mean them no particular harm I
won't fire animals if animals won't
bother me what perhaps I had better
amend that last sentence I won't
personally of other animals
I do feel though that a play breath of a
good cut of something rare is an affront
to the serious diner and that while I
have frequently run across the fellow
who could indeed be described as a
broccoli and potatoes man I cannot say
that I have ever really taken to such a
person
therefore I might more accurately state
that I do not like animals with two
exceptions the first being in the past
tense
at which point I liked them just fine in
the form of nice crispy spareribs and
bass region penny loafers and the second
being outside by which I mean not nearly
outside as an outside the house but
genuinely outside as an outside in the
woods or preferably outside in the South
American jungle this is after all only
fair I don't go there why should they
come here
the above being the case to think um is
no surprise that I do not approve of the
practice of keeping animals as pets not
approve is to my old pet should be
disallowed by law especially dogs
especially in New York City I have not
infrequently verbalized a sentiment it
when now passes for polite society and
have a very we've been the recipient of
the information that even if dogs should
be withheld from the frivolous there
would still be the blind and the
pathologically lonely to think of I am
not totally devoid of compassion and
after much thought I believe that I have
hit upon the perfect solution to this
problem let the lonely lead the blind
the implementation of this plan would
provide companionship to one and a sense
of direction to the other without
inflicting upon the rest of the populace
the all-too-common spectacle of grown
men addressing German shepherds in the
respectful tones best reserved for
elderly clergymen and internal revenue
agents you animal lovers uninterested in
helping news dealers across busy
intersections we'll just have to see
companionship elsewhere if actual
friends are not within your grasp may I
suggest that you take a cue from your
favorite celebrity and consider
investing in a really good entourage the
advantages of this such a scheme are an
estimable and entourage is its
indisputably superior to a dog or even
of course to actual friends and will
begin to pay for itself almost
immediately you do not have to walk in
entourage on the contrary one of the
major functions of an entourage is that
it walks you you do not have to name an
entourage you do not have to play with
an entourage you do not have to take a
non-price to the vet
although the conscientious entourage
owner makes certain that his entourage
has it all of its shots
you do of course have to feed
non-tourage but this can be accomplished
in decent Italian restaurants and
without the bother and mess of large tin
cans and special plastic dishes
if the entourage suggestion does not
appeal to you perhaps you should alter
your concept of companionship living
things need not enter into it at all
Jorge and silver and Duncan Phyfe sofas
make wonderful companions as do all
alcoholic beverages and out of season
fruits use your imagination study up on
the subject you'll think of something if
however you do not think of something
and animal lovers being a singer li
intractable lot chances are that you
won't I have decided to wreck the
remainder of my remarks to the actual
pets themselves in the hope that they
might at least learn to support
themselves with dignity and grace if you
are a dog and your owner suggests that
you wear a sweater suggest that he wear
tell if you have been named after a
human being artistic note run away from
home it is unthinkable that even an
animal should be obliged to share
quarters with anyone who cause a cat
Ford Madox Ford
dogs who earn their living by appearing
in television commercials in which they
constantly an aggressively demand meat
should remember that in at least one Far
Eastern country they are meat if you are
only a burden to go to cage count your
blessings
if you are an owl being kept as a pet
I applaud and encourage your tendency to
hoot you were to be highly commended for
expressing such an sentiment and now is
of course not a pet at all it is an
unforgivable and wistful effort in the
direction of whimsy no animals should
ever jump up on the dining room
furniture unless absolutely certain that
he can hold his own in the conversation
thank you
oh now be happy to answer your questions
all you have to do raise your hand yes
the question was one of my favorites is
can I tell you about my 10 euro writer's
block and what got me out of it well you
can imagine how uneventful
a 10 year writer's block is there isn't
really that much to tell
just imagine yourself sulking for a
decade um I don't know really know what
got me out of it
um I think that probably at a certain
point just around that 10-year mark
which you know to me now a decade just
seems like that I just missed my 30s
that was it um I think what probably got
me out of it was I think that the the
fear of not writer in writing became
greater than the fear of writing so is
it kind of um I believe all of life is
controlled by this kind of war of fears
whichever fear wins out most writers are
afraid unfortunately in my opinion um
that's right
but um so that's I think that's what
happened
well yes I got it wraps it up you're not
gonna forgive me for the animal thing
yes the question although of course I
would actually think of more as a
statement was that your parents seem
like perfectly decent people what
happened to you um well I'm not quite
sure my parents are perfectly decent
people you probably should ask they're
probably do they plant you in the
audience
um I think you know as I'm seeing it
alluded to before
um their primary complaint about me is
that I didn't go to college
this is uh despite the fact that I am
actually old enough to be a retired dean
at this point they still haven't
actually forgiven me for this and so
they they live in hope that I will
proceed with my education I know they
haven't forgiven me for that that's our
major complaint like right now I was to
go to college everything would be fine
in fact uh my mother wants to call me as
I was leaving for the airport I said I
can't speak to you right now I I have to
catch a plane she said where you going
and I said up to Harvard and she said
you are
and I said I'm going to give a speech
not to matriculate and she said you know
I think you could get in now
I don't by the way think I could get
into how I really dislike school very
intensely I like school up until about
seventh grade I like school I like
grammar school and that is because I
think we only like the things that we
excel at and I was a spectacular Grammar
School student and that is because I
went to a Grammar School where the
primary requirement was drawing pilgrims
and I was if not the best pilgrim drawer
one of the top three or four in the
country in the 50s when there was it was
very competitive and because I didn't
just draw pilgrims
in school I drew them in my free time
too because I think I imagined since it
was so stressed in my school I imagined
it being a really supreme importance and
so I would practice my program drawing
all the time effect
I was quite innovative in my pilgrim
drawing because I think I imagined that
at some point in my life I would be in a
circumstance where there would be a kind
of crisis and someone would shout can
anyone here draw a pilgrim
and I would race to the four and save
the day with my masterful pilgrim
drawing then of course I got past that
time in school and algebra replaced
pilgrim dry so really my poor
performance at school was also like my
writer's bucket was sulking I was in a
fury you know one day pilgrims the next
day algebra so I did extremely very very
poorly very poorly and on school once
algebra started and I disliked it I just
liked high school
tremendously now I'm this I really don't
think even you a critic of my life could
say that you enjoyed a high school I in
it I really believe that everyone hates
high school there's maybe two people in
every high school who are having fun
when is the captain the football team
the other ones his girlfriend so the
majority the vast majority of people
don't enjoy high school and i am i was
before i actually got expelled from
school city was kind of to say that I
dropped out which is kind of voluntary I
didn't drop out I was expelled but
before I got expelled it was preceded by
a number of suspensions one of which
occurred because I was caught sneaking
out of a pep rally because in my high
school pep was mandatory and although I
really disliked all sports I just liked
football the most now obviously I'm
speaking from the point of a spectator
football is the worst sport to watch
certainly it's played outside in cold
weather and it is not understandable you
can't understand at all football and
it's been explained to me a number of
times I can understand I also can't
understand why people think football
players are stupid because I think well
I understand football football to me is
um I would say these twin things
football tamiya´s algebra and motion and
so I didn't make it you know and so I
have really decided not to go to college
when I got expelled from high school it
was a very important day because I also
decided not to go to Meadows Medical
School that same day which is the real
thing my parents haven't forgive me for
her so I am NOT a doctor which was their
secret plan for me I don't know what you
asked but that's the answer yes why did
I write a children's book I wrote a
children's book mainly because I always
wanted to write it for this book and I
specifically mentioned to my editor
after my first book metropolitan out and
he said everyone who has a first book
that's a success wants to write a
children's book and that's because
they're scared to write their real book
and although this was true I was scared
to write my real book I actually think
of children's books as real books um and
I also never stopped reading them I just
kept reading them right along you know I
would children's book when I was little
then I started reading adult books and I
just kept also reading children's books
and so I just wanted to write one and
unlike every other thing that I was
wanted to do much to my surprise I
actually just did it so that's how I did
it and it was unlike any other
experience I have with writing since it
was actually enjoyable the the part that
I found to be the least enjoyable was
that because I can only draw pilgrims
and the book was not heavy on pilgrims I
had to have a collaborator an
illustrator and um you probably would be
surprised to hear that I don't really
don't work that well with others and so
I found it somewhat disconcerting to
have to even though Michael Graves who
did the illustrations is a close friend
of mine the idea of having to wait for
someone else when I'm supposed to be the
latest one was a little difficult but I
really enjoyed writing that book yes
what drives my humor well I would say
that I actually believe humor to be
someone who's humorous to be a choice
some people who have that what you might
call this drive are terrorists and some
are funny it's the same impulse right
like it's like either you can say
something or you can get a machine gun
uh-huh so I would say that would be the
drive I would say um you know it's a you
know it's graduated it could run
anywhere from annoyance to fury which is
why when people always say you know
can't you say something nice
apparently not
yes the question was do I have any
desire to go into film and the answer is
emphatically no I have have zero less
than zero um I didn't get that far math
but I know there is a less than zero no
and the reason it's not that I like
movie I love movies I love to go to the
movies um but I it is so not a writer's
medium I mean if I didn't like waiting
for Michael Graves to draw you can
imagine how much I'd like to hear the
opinion of an actor so that um you know
I have always um since my first book
came out received many offers to write
movies unless they would let the writers
be in control the movies which will
never occur I have no interest
whatsoever and in fact the cover of this
book which has it pictured me sleeping
in a screening room Toni Morrison
thought that the reason I have this
picture was to show that I'm rejecting
images instead of that I am slothful and
falling asleep but I do I love movies
but I would never want to write one I
would never really want to be an
employee they pay quite a bit for
writing movies and what they pay you for
is not the writing it's a listening to
them so uh no I have no interest in
doing yes
if I wish to be remembered for one thing
what would it be well you mean aside
from the pilgrims I mean there aren't
that many pilgrim drawings extent but
well I hope that um I would like to be
remembered for finally finishing my book
um I don't know we'll see if that
happens it's kind of a race against the
cigarettes
yes um well I think I really first
started writing when I was child as soon
as I could read in fact before I had
writing as a job before anyone was gonna
pay me to write I wrote all the time I
wrote constantly I did not start having
trouble writing until I got my first
professional assignment so I realized
that in fact it isn't only recently one
of the things that helped me get over my
writer's block was a realization that it
isn't writing I hate it's working I just
hate to work so I hate any job it
doesn't matter what it is so so I
started writing really when I was a
child and I was first published when I
was about 19 I think or 20 you know what
used to be called an underground
magazine a little tiny magazine where
the job I initially had there was
selling advertising but dumb since I
couldn't actually bring myself to call
anyone to ask them to put an ad in I
might convince the owner of this
publication that I would be better at
anything else and so that's when I
started publishing yes
they didn't get submission was there was
a New York Times magazine section had it
hold the whole magazine devoted to the
rich because you know I don't get enough
right and there was a an interview with
me in it she wondered if it was me it
was me well the complaint was that it
wasn't funny and but a but well done not
funny but well done in she was she
couldn't believe what was made because
it was so unfunny well I guess you're
not that rich it was funny to them yes
who is my editor and what kind of
religion pay well actually my editors
recently he died he was a man and Joe
Fox and he was at Random House for 35
years and now my editor is Sonny Maeda
at Knopf and basically I feel that the
editor writer relationship really
consists of being taken out to very
expensive dinners
I don't allow anyone to edit my work I
find the whole notion of editing bizarre
there's no other kind of work where
people do that I mean no one goes up to
painter and says uh-uh below so I have
never allowed line editing my feeling is
you're a better writer than me right so
that um I feel that it's basically a
restaurant situation and so um it
doesn't really matter to me who my
editors from a point of view of align it
in Joe Fox was probably the most highly
regarded line editor in this country but
I didn't take advantage of that at all
um and when I send my menus from sim
which is you know every decade or so um
I write stet on the top and it goes in
so um that's my relationship hostel
friendly with any other contemporary
writers and have said that they have a
influence on my work I have very few
friends who are writers this is
deliberate they really don't make the
best companions in my opinion you'd be
surprised how to say and generous
writers are to one another and how they
may not actually be rooting for you
so I have a few friends where writers um
but but not there they're the minority
of my friends and none of them
influenced me from the point of view of
what I write Toni Morrison is a close
friend of mine and she and Felicity's
very much to try to get me to write and
so that although I think that Toni's
actually been quite a poor influence on
me because she did kind of suck me into
a year of watching the menendez trial
and I watched the entire trial on the
telephone with her which started in I
was living a prison that year and
started around 1:00 in the afternoon and
I felt okay about it
because she was doing it too so I
thought well Tony's already sorry for me
to do it that was I didn't realize she
got up at 5 o'clock in the morning and
by the time she she called to watch the
trial she was done this was a secret to
her success so that done but I actually
fight Tony Bieber extremely inspiring
relationship in my life but not from
point of view but actually what I write
but just as a kind of a model of a
person who can write and watch the
menendez triumph at the same time that's
my aspiration yes what authors do you
like to read what authors do I like to
read well I am an extremely um I'm
really a bookworm I mean if I really
read all the time instead of them say
writing um and um I read almost only
fiction I have very little interest in
actual facts and I'm I'm such a
promiscuous reader
I am the [ __ ] of literature so I'm such
a Prince's reader that I really couldn't
say exactly what writers I like and I
like many many writers to read not to
eat with
yes I think it was a year or two ago you
wrote an essay in near vanilla that
right no it was you see this is another
complaint have you met her question was
it that she had read an interview that I
did in marybelle magazine that was quite
serious said somewhat Disney
disapprovingly and it was a lot about
politics and could I comment further on
that the the interview was actually
entitled if I were dictator which is
pretty much the main comment I could
make about my political stance and so
there were a lot of questions of what I
would do if I was the dictator United
States the reason it was dictators that
a president was understandable right I
mean it's very hard to rule in a
democracy and as you can see nothing can
get done so I am available by the way
for this position it is my second choice
my first being Pope Pope is preferable
to dictator they last longer but I'm
available for the papacy in case anyone
here has any poll I don't I don't know
you and this has always been my first
career choice I think without question
the Pope has the best job in the world I
mean he never has to look for an
apartment
he has great clothes and people kneel
when he comes into the room
so I hope I answered your question yes
could I please talk about my sister and
my relationship with her I have a
younger sister her name is Ellen our
relationship is one of sisters she is my
younger sister
but unfortunately my taller sister and
she's been taller than me she's almost
40 of them she's been taller than me
almost my entire life when she was born
she was taller than me so I have yet to
forgive him for this other than that she
just she's a sister
tall tall younger sister all right now I
could deal with it you know if your
sister was born taller than you when you
and your 40s it would be all right but
as a child because then you you need
that height of any the advantage the
physical advantage I was deprived to
this this is my parents fault this was a
kind of pre-emptive attack by my parents
said in case I ever got kicked out of
high school
yes questions you worked with Warhol
what was it like
well first so I didn't work with him I
work for him this locution people
working with each other something I
really disapprove of people don't really
work with each other do they someone
works for someone else but we don't say
that anymore do we we live this kind of
haze of misspoken language now so people
say things like this is my cleaning lady
she works with me
I'm the chairman the board of General
Motors we work together I worked for
Andy I didn't work with him I would
actually rather have worked for Andy
than with him to tell you the truth
because that way I'm not responsible for
his work and it was and I started
working there when I was about 20 and
you know was it an unusual environment
for a writer since very few people in
that environment where that oh I was
gonna say literary but I could even say
literate um but it was a I couldn't have
gotten a job at a real magazine for that
you would actually have to have finished
high school going to college and but
that they didn't have any kind of
standards there well they had standards
but not professional standards and so I
qualified for the unprofessional
standards and it wasn't unusual it's it
not really the sort of question you can
answer in one sentence or paragraph but
it wasn't Time Inc I could tell you that
yes in your invitation to the Graduate
School of Design at Harvard was that
because you have any special interest or
expertise and
architecture I mean I spoke at the
questions I spoke at the Graduate School
designer Harvard which is a architecture
school and he's wondering what actually
my mother gave voice to when I told her
I was going to Harvard to speak the
architecture school when he was why
would they ask you do I have any special
expertise well I think so I have a
special interest in architecture and
perfect taste thank you very much
thank you all very much for coming um
Fran will moved to the next room to sign
books if you like you can see why we
keep inviting her back again she's not
only the first person who ever spoke for
us at the Hertz theatre I think she is
our most frequent guest so thank you all
for being here